she grew up in Minneapolis she's a
member of both the Ojibwe and Dakota
tribes and because she didn't grow up on
their reservation she has sometimes
wondered if she can be the authentic
voice for the stories that she most
wants to tell but I think that when you
get a chance to read her screenplays or
said girls you will agree with these
judges that Winona is the true voice
that we've been waiting for I do think
it's really common for writers to ask
themselves I might the one to tell the
story do I even know how it's a very
common feeling when you begin a new
screenplay but for one none of that
sense of uncertainty I think was
compounded because she had already
abandoned a dream when she was young she
dropped out of school got married had
three kids left her life left her kids
but there was a little voice in her that
said there has to be more from me and at
30 in a restless moment she picked up a
book on screenwriting and a whole world
opened for her and building on nothing
more than her love for movies for being
a watcher of movies Winona began writing
I do think that writing can be learned
but I don't really think that it can be
taught I think that we are all
essentially autodidact we write badly at
first we write clumsily it's very
humbling screenwriting seems like
something that anyone can do until you
try to do it
[Laughter]
and Wynonna wrote numerous screenplays
as she worked to develop her gifts as a
screenwriter she applied to the Academy
nickel a lot of times blind faith I
think is the first prerequisite for a
person who's teaching themselves to
write and I am really glad that Winona
kept the faith in herself through 22
screenplays that she wrote before she
rose to this
wenona I just want to say that your
apprenticeship to all of the movies that
you watched and studied has really paid
off and I can safely attest that you are
really a real screenwriter and I hope
there is a producer out here who's a
student enough to option your screenplay
that it's the right producer and that
they help you bring this movie into the
world may you inspire us deeply again
with the screenplay that you're gonna
write this year as a nickel feller
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
hi you guys so well that was that was
really great thank you
cuz that was fun okay
first off congratulations to my fellow
fellows it's been an incredible week and
I'm so happy we got to experience it
together and make memories that will
look back on forever
congratulations you guys that's great
I'd like to thank the Academy the nickel
committee and this year's judges for
championing championing my work and
keeps keep saying yes all of your kind
words support and love for Horsehead
Girls has humbled me and given me a
sense of pride and accomplishment thanks
to Joan Chris and Jacob you have been
our patient guides throughout this past
month and especially this week you love
your job and it really shows thank you
to my amazing family my husband Edie
my boys Cooper McCallister and Benjamin
and thanks to my friends and family that
loved and encouraged me you know who you
are and I love you all so much
it says breathe here
November is Native American Heritage
Month and to tell you about myself as a
writer I have to tell you about my own
Native American heritage the first
screenplay I wrote was based on my
grandmother's childhood she was a Dakota
Indian in 1926 at the age of five she
was kidnapped from her reservation by
two strange men in suits thrown into the
back of a car and taken across state
lines to a mandated government-run
Indian boarding school she had no
contact with her parents for the next
seven years she suffered many forms of
abuse neglect and isolation and was
systematically stripped of her culture
and family and life as she knew it
anyone that knows a five year old think
about that people love that script they
said your story needs to be told this is
your history your voice should be heard
and then followed by but nobody will
watch a film with a female native
protagonist you have no audience no
actors and no investors lesson learned I
spent the next 16 years writing about
zombies aliens and highschool girls and
I worked on being a better writer a
better storyteller and better prepared
to stand for and write about something I
believe in that's when I learned about
the missing and murdered indigenous
women movement and I knew what I had to
do now 18 years after that first script
Here I am once again writing about
Native American girls being kidnapped
abused and forgotten it hasn't stopped
it never stopped but this time is
different
today I'm hearing this story will be
told this is our history and your voice
is being heard because there is an
audience and we will find actors and
people want to help and the weight and
the work and the patience was all worth
it and today I'm able to honor my
grandmother her mother and all the
people who are missing someone taken
from them her name was Katherine and
this is for her McGlinn